hoy vamos directo a ciudad de panamá el
gobierno de laurentino cortizo instaló
este jueves 14 de julio una mesa de
negociaciones para intentar buscar una
solución a las protestas que ya llevan
más de una semana sin embargo la alianza
pueblo unido por la vida y la alianza
nacional por los derechos del pueblo
organizado que son las impulsoras de la
huelga no participarán conectamos a esta
hora con nuestro corresponsal oscar
sulbarán oscar bienvenido aquí a
france24 su casa cuéntanos cómo van los
diálogos y por qué los principales
promotores de las manifestaciones no se
unieron a la mesa
o la mezclará como bien decía el
presidente de la república al aventino
cortizo convocó a una mesa de diálogo
para este jueves en esa convocatoria
acudió el presidente de la república
acudió parte de su gabinete también una
comisión de la asamblea nacional de
diputados y una representación de la
iglesia pues el gobierno solicitó que la
iglesia fuera mediadora en estos
diálogos durante el acto de instalación
de esta mesa de diálogo el presidente a
la república reconoció las protestas de
los ciudadanos sin embargo también
denunció que había infiltrados personas
personajes políticos infiltrados que
trataban de dañar los legítimos reclamos
de la población los grandes ausentes de
esta mesa de diálogo instalada por el
gobierno en la ciudad capital fueron los
representantes de las principales
organizaciones gremiales y sindicales
que llevan la bandera de este
de este conflicto el principal motivo
que ellos expusieron para no asistir es
que pedían que todo lo que se revisara
de ahora en adelante fuese consensuado
están de acuerdo con un diálogo pero
creen que todo lo que se debe realizar
en torno a diálogo desde la mediación
hasta los temas debe realizarse en forma
consensuada y las protestas comenzaron
en contra del alza del precio del
combustible que subió un 47% en el
último semestre sin embargo luego se
ampliaron las razones del paro y ahora
también repudian por ejemplo el
despilfarro del dinero público cuéntenos
a qué se deben las protestas y cómo ha
respondido el gobierno
las protestas comenzaron hace 14 días en
el interior del país regó se fueron
multiplicando se intensificaron justo
cuando el presidente de la república
estaba fuera del país luego llega el
presidente de la república anuncia una
serie de medidas entre ellas el
congelamiento del precio de la gasolina
a 13 95 el galón también la inclusión de
algunos productos en la canasta
alimentaria en un control de precios de
canasta alimentaria y un también un
proceso de anuncios que tienen que ver
con la contención de gastos precisamente
por esos llamados que esas peticiones
que ha hecho la gente sin embargo han
sido tanto los gremios que se han unido
a esta manifestación que han aumentado
los reclamos y las peticiones
gracias a buscar por este completo
reporte desde panamá nosotros
continuamos con más información